parfois je vous raconte
j'ai cherché je cherchais je cherchais
je me fis qu'est-ce qui en plus du
panache
et le monde entier et ce qui vient de se
passer la république les émissions sont
principalement par contre
on répète ce genre nous
allons allons
tous nous
[Musique]
en sommes en
entrepreneuriat social
aux roulariens
applicative tous types de dollars
mais en même temps chacun a sa vie
surtout ce qu'il lui faudrait comme
ressource hu a démarré pour les uns trop
naïve
au certain et une école de résultats
sont là explique un document dans un
mouvement
c'est l'ancien
chef du protocole sont beaucoup beaucoup
au club et lance je pense que tous les
paramètres
il préfère la série mini
et la fougue de la jeunesse contrepoint
il pas d'argent ils vont la rejoindre
sans argent aux grosses à la main
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas devant nous
parce que j'ai réussi non je suis du
monde parce que j'ai des ressources
particulièrement partage
et 7 reçus cela je la bretelle à un
monsieur qui j'ai beaucoup d'estimé qui
s'appelle le master and servant quelques
règles et d'imagés
cette douce ou c'est le coup
et là vous allez me dire oh la
la
alors la côte je m'appelle
je fais mes études en france à 24 ans
je dis
les études c'est bon j'investis fallait
je ne fais il faut que je parle ici faut
que tout change de sousse sfax à moscou
et la merde en plus de questions
elle bâtit une autre blonde seigneur
[Musique]
pour certains domaines d'activité où
certaines personnes vous demanderai pas
ce que vous en avez les compétences
capacités compétences ou aller les
chercher comme les autres à 24 ans alors
que vous êtes l'homme est une famille
lundi janne travaillait dans le service
à la langue classique et vous allez
expliquer à vos pas mal mais aux études
en france que vous allez me dire
ne riez pas cette pression
mes capacités entrepreneuriales sont
plus l'envié de dire de ma première
passion qui est la logique
dans les années 68 on avait l'équipe i
après un bac l instar mouvement les
et intérêts le coupé décalé
étudie range ans j'ai commencé à
organiser des soirées parce que j'avais
la musique elle soirée par sylvette m du
monde qu'un jour
évidemment qu'avec moins de
fibres synthétiques son salut à mon goût
elle m'a dit j'ai entendu dire que tu
sais les soirées moi je vais à la
moutète
même si tu peux tu penses que tu as cité
l'avoir de faire une soirée est chez moi
je te confie les rênes de la boîte et on
va travailler ça arrivait région plus
tangible et donc je vous parle de sa
main droite là vous voyez sur affiches
j'étais dj
awadi la région va pas mieux parce que
c'est pas les métissages
mais j'étais à la femme armani
et portier aussie était si j'avais le
vestiaire de savon
à la première soirée libre et ce truc ça
parce que c'est ce qui va marcher nous à
la première soirée
il y avait même du monde est longue et
dans les salles la première soirée
patrick est calme et la bonne voie
estime nguyên de marine libre j'ai vu
dans ma peau ni de ne pas d'un mariage
c'est pour ça que les applications
payantes
elles activent au caire lorsque tu auras
faire beaucoup de choses avec ton et
c'est là que j'avais démarré par la
région tampon mariable jamais encore je
crois même deux ans et j'ai fait ça
pendant cinq ans me dit toujours que
jamais plus beau job étudiant sahraoui
l'ingestion sa mamie la gestion du fils
12 images d'agressions les emprunts
dijon tranquille et ça m'a donné toutes
les capacités nécessaires
veuillez le limoger entrepreneuriat
au projet interne par un déclic
j'ai constaté que les districts digital
à saragosse de produire des sites
internet de qualité pour les entreprises
encore à ses balbutiements mais avait
des réponses de la luz je lance donc
encore loin et là je n'ai pas en janvier
chaigneau qui n'ont jamais autres
preneurs de virgin nous qui me disais
que si c'est ça qui me fait une jolie
brochette avant d'être pacifique et bien
tu peux le laisser croître
de
2 solution inc donc je commence les
lames c'est la petite équipe de trois
employés petite sarl au capital de 20
millions et dans nos conventions
commence on commence et à rim dont on
arrive tous progressivement sur le
premier village qui s'appelle virage
autour opportunités
qu'est ce qui nous pose de mines et lui
redonner plus tôt selon la mairie mais
demande à même sa culpabilité
[Musique]
j'ai envie de dieu qu'on le reconnaît
comme en tunisie et à sa capacité à
transformer nos positions en faisant
appel
aux compétences locales à ce qu elles
sont
ça veut dire que ça sonne tellement
évident l'homme est tellement pas
évident moins que sa venue opportunité
pour parce que c'est toujours pour le
jeune papa est là bas ça reste un peu
flou alors tu sais mon propos je choisis
le piano match
parce que tout le monde connaît
visiblement
le connaissent mieux et j'assume
et sa peine car ça va
ça de monsieur qui avait la capacité
mais gameiro guillaume anies
dans la famille un jour y passe ils vont
amener du 4éme étage et une housse apple
c'est fort la combine
est bien de ses fans il a la capacité
que m
et certains qui veulent réaliser était
la personne qui s'est remis qui se
rendre dans 23 juil de couilles je n'ai
pas vu sur la une
alors j'aimerais vous dire à ce stade de
mon propos que
la capacité l'opportunité nous ramène
quelque chose qu'à ma tête
c'est que
tu es
forcément pas plus on n'a pas forcément
que cet âge là m'a franchement besoin
d'une grande expérience dans quelque
chose pour nous la loi déjà c'est une
capacité et aux émissaires conduite est
à ce prix
c'est ce que nous avons fait mais
je vous ai dit tantôt que j'étais dans
le digital alors une multinationale de
d'élégance approche ma petite entreprise
moi partie écoutez on distribue des
menus et sous menus très joli et gaz
opérateurs et on n'arrive pas
luthérienne qui va nous permettre de
signer les artistes line et d'étudier
les phases occitane nature et ses 13
buts et deux fils évidence des activités
des mois que mia vendredi mais les
artistes croise
celle émise
donc ici vous voyez quel penalty ce que
vous connaissez je pense qu'il est
d'abord aussi riche elle m'a mise en
place même saisi à déterminer vraiment
le premier virage que mon âme achemine
ensuite un de nos clients est venu me
voir et m'a dit je refais ritcher je
veux que tu fais et j'ai décidé donc moi
je suis fier d'être à paunat à
l'intérieur de mon entreprise c'est à
dire créer ultime d'un gouvernement qui
lui ont dit non au tourisme
je ne connais rien comme vous l'avez
surtout on essaie de passer du titane a
l'habitude d'un parement sont intéressés
les amines
et progressivement je commence à avoir
une position à sir important dans notre
bouche quand j étais jeune roi 27 comme
chantait il était à peu près 400 traduit
donc j'ai environ à bruno sido
c'est à ce moment là
que on se dit qu'on a réussi jeudi quand
les sketches sociale j'étais que pour
l'europe n'a pas donné tout ça c'est ça
la différence par notre collègue les
pistes possibles tels que l'auto n'a
semble hélas toujours vous et changer
les choses alors je resterai avec super
2000 avec toutes les conditions que
jamais
à cause de la lettre suivante qui a lui
dit si le désir de vouloir changer les
choses
je crée une entreprise cette fois dans
le dos mais recule la discussion pour
moi parce que j'étais dans cette société
agricole j'ai remarqué que j'avais
beaucoup de mal à transférer de l'argent
permet de jouer en village ou planqués à
noter dans les différentes plages ou non
je vais donc j'ai créé cette entreprise
là parce que je me suis dit il faut que
le réseau puisse bénéficier qui sont
venus donc commencer non seulement je
crains donc
au capital de 1 2 million qui bouge on
brasse il
est effectivement dans la culture à
l'avenir les et quand je fais le tour
des villages pour leur expliquer mon
concept l'agricul avec le digital on
peut là hop est allé plus loin des
villes plus comme choisir
je continue cette entreprise
jusqu'au gong pratique il en otage en
allemagne note ronald où je perds
je perde du mal il faut je suis
maintenant d'aidé envers les raidisseurs
mes clients et dixon pourquoi parce que
dans ce domaine pourtant sert encore de
l'argent cash
alors quand vous perdez 70 90 à qui on
minimisait africana
c'est de là qu'est parti en vidéo du
recul et le désir ici de changer les
choses est entretenu par balles aux
sources de motivation c'est là que les
anthropologues sérieux comme les
salariés mutés le diamant est venu vers
se retirer par quelques si vous allumez
entrepris
pour ma part en premier lieu j'ai
rarement connu
jean montreux vieux mais je pense que ça
sérieusement dans cette démo façon de
voir le jour
il est aussi la famille
qui compte sur vous y'avait pas
qu'est-ce qui fait c'est quoi ce travail
et il ya aussi changer les choses mais a
surtout fait connaître
surtout les données
allant prendre j'ai trop
mal que le jardin est ce que c'est ce
qu'il suffirait de miser sur par arnaud
je pense que toute marque de café elles
célèbrent ce matin qu'elle avait
deux gars qui sait qu'il fallait d'avis
évident
parce que c'est la seule personne à être
entré au comté ou d'un petit voire de
dôme et différents
chanteurs et fut pas le cas imaginerait
que la plus jeune fille qui l'avait
marqué les mains clipser de la
conversion
et le troisième sur un docteur qui
s'appelle local ou en ligne et qui est
d'intérêt général benoît thans outils et
diarra a rejoint le magic system qui
vont cette critique n'était là que java
mois
arrive donc sur les efforts à réaliser
pour bouge un projet de connectique de
bancarisation cette pub tu sais que la
zone rurale sa pulpe au bouddha et
monter un salon de jeu
je ne savais pas par avance il y avait
deux solutions avant de raymond projet
mon rêve d'une banque a raison l'épisode
le plus curieux c'est bien arrivé à nos
packs en outre on faire en sorte que ça
va éprouver les trois mondes
j'avais cette citation sur l'épaule
tandis que le baril se appelle la chance
est en fait la rencontre de bouc bouches
il dit aimer les gens il faut aller au
tapis talent dans le coup
qu'est ce que chaque jour pour jour que
ce ton si j'allais prochain rachat lui
laissant
alors en charge non celle de l'amour une
manne des t-shirts
et discothèques
j'avais une chose et démocratique
n'hésitez pas plus généralement projet
paradoxalement j'évolue du piment
pour
continuer ma vie toujours parmi les
eskimos l'a carrément c'est mon projet
l'entreprise que dirige aujourd'hui qui
est cette solution qu au caire à
destination des femmes et je les perçois
tu sais bien en jambes et qui ne
nécessite donc aucune connotation voir
la carte parce que je veux le faire
revenir ici c'est que j'y serai jamais
digéré le match on sait tous ce qui est
imputable à moitié les coachs si ce
n'est pas de l'argent ce n'est pas
l'expérience
c'était beaucoup
je dirais un bon petit zoom
une citation que celle bien qu'elle
l'efficacité de la ressource dépôt de la
qualité de la source on ne peut pas
faire les crocs en
1h59 sommes sans doute
aujourd'hui si vous êtes face à un
challenge si vous êtes face à lui et
vous avez dépassé par le bruit suspect
si celle où surmonter ces défis
rappelez vous qu'un jour je leur ai
jamais parlé du comme aux autres